avec nous il sera bonjour Yves merci
d'être avec nous directeur adjoint dans
la rédaction du figa Royal no Benedetti
bonjour
Quentin nous a rejoint c'est vendredi on
va revenir avec vous sur la semaine
politique marquée par les vives tensions
à l'Assemblée autour de la proposition
de loi du groupe la majorité a réussi à
supprimer le retour à 62 ans avec un
vote mais les invectives ont fuser entre
majorité de coaguré des débats
électriques jeudi prochain lors de
l'examen en séance et puis on parlera du
rassemblement national pointé du doigt
dans la commission d'enquête sur les
ingérences étrangères qu'il a lui-même
demandé le rapport accuse le RN d’être
une courroie de transmission du pouvoir
russe rapport malhonnête et politisée
c'est sûr je Marine Le Pen on va en
parler d'abord en regardant l'actualité
dans nos régions
[Musique]
et l'actualité dans nos régions avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
à Avignon retrouver Stéphane pulse
bonjour Stéphane merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous grand reporters Dauphiné
Libéré Stéphane vous vous allez nous
mettre l'eau à la bouche avec un article
sur un chef étoilé qui propose une
cuisine un peu particulière
oui tout à fait c'est une belle histoire
dans le dans le Luberon avec Nadia Samut
une jeune chef étoilée qui propose une
cuisine sans gluten et sans lactose
et ce qui est très intéressant c'est que
c'est parti d'un constat personnel
puisqu'elle était intolérante assez
produite d'une famille de cuisinière sa
maman était une célèbre reine s'amuse
une célèbre chef cuisinière dans les
années 90 et vous imaginez elle ne
pouvait même pas rentrer dans la cuisine
de sa maman à cause de la simple
volatilité de la farine par exemple de
blé et un jour elle a décidé de d'abord
de s'en sortir parce que c'était très
compliqué elle était très malade et puis
de d'inventer une cuisine où tout le
monde peut se réunir à sa table
et Stéphane comment elle en est venue à
proposer ce concept
elle a fait le tour elle a décidé de
d'abord d'aller
d'enlever tout ce qui pouvait déjà lui
nuire titre personnel en inversant les
polarités quelque part c'est à dire
enlever ces produits qui sont très
compliqués pour quand on est intolérant
au gluten au lactose et de proposer une
alternative parce qu'il en existe on
prendra le pois chiche pois chiche peut
faire de la farine on peut vous imaginer
que le pois chiche on peut même faire du
lait et on peut même faire de la glace
c'est assez incroyable donc c'est une
cuisine à base essentiellement de
produits de la mer de légumes et ce qui
était très intéressant c'est que du coup
à sa table à la fainière du côté de
Lourmarin ben du coup on peut réunir
tout le monde autour de produits
finalement qui rassemble au lieu de
diviser
merci Stéphane merci beaucoup de nous
avoir parlé de cette chef étoilé on
regarde la une du Dauphiné aujourd'hui
bar et resto pour recruter le système D
c'est à la Une de votre journée merci
beaucoup Stéphane d'avoir été avec nous
on va faire le récap de l'actualité de
la semaine l'actualité politique sans
grand suspense marquer une nouvelle fois
par la question de la réforme des
retraites et cette proposition de loi du
groupe lot alors cette semaine Quentin
c'était l'examen en commission de cette
proposition de loi et on a vu une
nouvelle tentative des opposants à la
réforme des retraites d'abroger le texte
proposition de loi depuis le début du
mois de mai j'ai retrouvé une chronique
qu'on avait fait dans ce club le 5 mai
pourquoi son employait depuis si
longtemps parce qu'en fait avec le rejet
du deuxième RIB soutenez-vous Vous
demandez par la gauche en fait et bien
c'était devenu un peu le dernier espoir
des opposants à la réforme des retraites
pour rejeter le texte avec une
configuration particulière parce que
c'est un progression de la réforme était
par un petit groupe d'élusent triste le
fameux groupe lyaute et on avait même vu
cette image que vous voyez en ce moment
même la gauche debout qui applaudissait
le député liotte Charles de Courson qui
est à l'origine du texte et même des
députés du RN qui de l'autre côté de
l'émission c'était levé pour également
l'applaudir voilà cette coalition qui
s'était donc formée autour de ce groupe
culotte la première bataille autour de
ce texte vous l'avez dit elle sait jouer
en commission des affaires sociales à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est toujours la
première étape lorsque et bien on
examine une proposition là ou un projet
de loi on sait que l'exécutif et la
macronie voulait tout faire pour que cet
abrogation de la réforme des retraites
ne soient jamais adopté on sait que le
symbole aurait été terrible résultat une
ambiance délétère lors de cette réunion
de la commission regardez un extrait
madame la Présidente je veux faire une
alerte solennelle sur nos conditions de
travail il y a 10 députés 11 députés
maintenant qui sont debout dans cette
commission et la honte madame la
Présidente c'est que ce sont les
pompiers qui sont en train de chercher
s'il n'y a pas une autre salle parce
qu'ils ont constaté qu'il y avait des
problèmes de sécurité dans cette salle
on a vu des dizaines de rappels au
règlement comme cela avec toujours ce
ton très tendu entre la macronie et les
oppositions en fait toute la question
était encore une fois de savoir ce
qu'elle allait faire les LR dans le vote
on le sait il est pivot à l'Assemblée
nationale et dans ce dossier
particulièrement le président de groupe
n'a pas pris de risque il a demandé à
deux députés favorables à la réforme de
siéger en commission regardez maintenant
le moment du vote en commission les
résultats
du temps
et donc les amendements de suppression
sont adoptés en conséquence l'article
1er est supprimé monsieur
à votre mes chers collègues vous
demandiez le vote il y a eu un vote on
le respecte vous venez de le voir
l'article 1 qui abroge la réforme des
retraites et qui revient sur le passage
de 62 à 64 ans a donc été supprimé en
commission une victoire pour la majorité
présidentielle dans la foulée la nuque à
tenter en vain de déposer des milliers
de sous amendements pour espérer ne pas
aller au bout de l'examen du texte
pourquoi parce qu'un style et bien le
texte initial avec son article 1 et bien
c'est ce texte là qui sera arrivé en
séance publique dans l'hémicycle le 8
juin refus de la présidente renaissance
de la commission tous cette bataille
parlementaire elle sait maintenant
invitée ensuite aux questions
d'actualité du gouvernement du Sénat le
mercredi après-midi et écouter la
première ministre qui a fustigé et bien
la position et l'action de la nuque
ce matin la commission
a voté et supprimer l'article de la
proposition de loi qui visait à abroger
la réforme des retraites c'est un vote
clair et démocratique mais immédiatement
après laupes a répondu par l'obstruction
avec le dépôt de 3000 sous amendements
pour empêcher un vote finale en
commission
la réalité c'est que lorsque le résultat
d'un vote déplaît à la nupasse elle n'a
qu'une réponse l'obstruction voilà pour
cette déclaration de la première
ministre c'était donc mercredi
après-midi au Sénat prochaine étape dans
cette bataille parlementaire c'est le 8
juin les députés examineront maintenant
la proposition de loi en séance dans
l'hémicycle mais il n'y aura plus
l'article phare de cette proposition de
loi il sera très difficile de
réintroduire la mesure car la présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale il y a une
drôle Pivet et bien elle pourrait
s'opposer à tout nouvel amendement de
réintroduction puisqu'elle dispose de ce
pouvoir désormais merci pour ce résumer
alors on a vu un nouvelle semaine tendu
entre la majorité et la nuque notamment
qui a remporté la bataille cette semaine
d'abord aux félicitations pour cette
mise en scène parce que c'est pas simple
deuxièmement qui a remporté voilà c'est
pas c'est pas ceux qui veulent se poser
qui ont qui ont remporté c'est à dire
ceux qui se sont opposés à cette réforme
j'entends je pense que vraiment là les
Français ils comprennent plus grand
chose la procédure est compliquée à
suivre
je ne suis pas certain que le personnel
politique gagne en crédit en montrant ce
spectacle et je pense que beaucoup de
Français même s'ils sont hostiles au
fait de travailler plus longtemps on
voudrait passer à autre chose et que la
page soit tournée avec quand même on
retiendra dans cette épisode
un summum de bêtises et de d'hypocrisie
alors bêtise bon le mot était peut-être
le mot était peut-être un peu fort mais
de je veux dire le spectacle donné est
un spectacle médiocre
ou il y a peu d'arguments finalement et
l'argument les arguments les plus
massifs qui peuvent être des arguments
d'ordre démographique ou qui peuvent
être des arguments d'ordre sociaux
social n'ont pas été n'ont pas été
développés ça a été vraiment un jeu de
cours de récréation et puis tout ça
porté par un groupe qui n'est pas un
groupe centriste contrairement à ce que
vous avez dit là c'est un groupe
composite fait de gens vraiment
d'univers très particulier
mais très
variés
Charles de Courson qui a quelques années
réclamait la retraite à 65 ans on est
dans le bal des hypocrites et dans un
jeu politique qui moi me désespèrent un
peu Arnaud vous êtes aussi sévère qui
non je pense pas moi je pense que il y a
un vrai problème démoc pratique et que
la première ministre et la majorité
pratique l'inversion accusatoire quand
ils disent vous ne le voulez pas aller
au vote pourquoi l'exécutif n'est pas
allé au vote en séance plénière
c'est-à-dire devant les députés il y
avait cette possibilité je crois que
c'est une erreur politique et que sur la
distance ça se payera c'est ça et ça
risque de se payer assez cher parce
qu'il y a une forme d'asphyxie
démocratique si vous voulez un moment
donné vous ne pouvez pas couper toutes
les routes de la démocratie on pratique
pas la démocratie sociale on ne veut pas
discuter avec les syndicats on leur
impose on leur impose une loi qui dont
il ne à laquelle il s'oppose notamment
les plus réformistes vous ne vous voyez
pas pratiquer la démocratie directe
c'est-à-dire le référendum oui il vous
reste la démocratie parlementaire vous
la coupez vous coupez la route de la
démocratie parlementaire indéniablement
aujourd'hui vous avez une majorité de
Français qui reste fondamentalement
opposée et hostile à cette réforme
certes ils vont passer à autre chose
parce que l'été va arriver on va changer
de séquence indéniablement mais la
réalité qui va finalement continuer à
infuser
le fonctionnement de nos institutions
qui est en jeu à travers ce texte et qui
pourra être en jeu à travers d'autres
textes oui moi je suis pas d'accord avec
ça je pense que la démocratie elle
laisse que les gens en font est-ce que
les élus en font
il y a lavé la volonté de la part de
tous les de tous ceux qui s'opposaient à
cette à ce texte d'abord c'est pas vrai
qu'il y a pas eu de dialogue il y a eu
un dialogue avec les syndicats depuis le
début je suis désolé et d'abord et
deuxièmement les syndicats ce ne sont
pas eux qui gouvernent au sauf preuve du
contraire ils sont pas élus non non une
gouverne pas les syndicats sont là il y
a un dialogue avec eux on essaye de
trouver des voies de passage les
syndicats sont aussi responsables du
bazar qui a dans ce pays que le
personnel politique ça c'est la première
des choses la deuxième des choses c'est
vrai qu'on est dans un système peut-être
usé sur le plan institutionnel où il
faudrait davantage de poids ou Parlement
ça j'en conviens avec avec beaucoup de
ça j'en conviens beaucoup j'en conviens
que on a un parlement qui est très qui
est une chambre des enregistrement et
quand il n'est plus une chambre des
registrements parce que sa composition
est beaucoup moins je dirais homogène
que ne voulait le président de la de
Gaulle et que ça devient une chambre
finalement de la Quatrième République
c'est plus compliqué ça c'est clair
c'est ce qui se passe là on pensait pas
que ça pouvait arriver un jour mais moi
je j'estime que il y a aussi on n'a pas
eu un débat de fond sur le sur le sur le
sujet et si on n'a pas eu ces battements
c'est parce qu'il y avait une opposition
qui était une opposition primaire qui
était une opposition qui est des
oppositions même qui n'avait qu'un seul
objectif c'était d'une certaine façon de
faire tomber le gouvernement sans le
faire tomber d'ailleurs parce qu'elle
savait très bien que si elle faisait
tomber le gouvernement bah tout le monde
sombrer avec lui donc il y avait je
trouve là il y a un peu de mauvaise foi
on se on se dit moi je suis pas sûr que
ça laisse beaucoup de traces finalement
ça va passer on va passer à autre chose
maintenant ils vont entreprises sur
l'immigration
et voilà on est on est malheureusement
c'est vrai un peu dans le registre de
l'immobilisme non juste un point moi la
vraie question c'est de savoir si on
peut gouverner contre l'opinion publique
en l'occurrence qui majoritairement
encore une fois restent hostile à ce
texte quoi qu'on pense de ce texte c'est
la réalité l'autre sujet c'est que là où
je suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec
qui c'est que là la République est une
république sociale constitutionnellement
il faut jamais l'oublier donc on doit
d'une certaine manière aussi produire un
certain nombre de politiques publiques
notamment ce type de politique publique
avec les syndicats et quand les
syndicats sont unanimes finalement
contre une mesure on peut considérer
qu'il y a un problème donc ça je crois
que c'est un sujet qui est un sujet
majeur ensuite je ne suis pas sûr que
les institutions soient usées c'est la
façon dont on utilise les institutions
aujourd'hui qui posent problème en
l'occurrence et le vrai sujet et là je
rejoins ce que dit y c'est que en effet
on va s'échapper sur d'autres sujets
c'est que le vrai problème qui va
réapparaître dans les semaines qui
viennent et dans les mois qui viennent
c'est l'absence de majorité dans cette
Assemblée nationale et c'est cette
absence de majorité qui rend très
précaire l'existence de cette
législature et on va le voir très vite
lors du texte sur l'immigration et c'est
vrai que moi je suis d'accord avec vous
ici vous me le permettez mais vous
disiez le débat n'est pas allé au bois à
cause de l'obstruction venu de la nuque
mais je crois que cette obstruction elle
a rangé énormément le gouvernement qui
n'a jamais voulu aller au vote dans
l'hémicycle parce qu'il n'y avait pas de
majorité pour voter le texte infini donc
il y avait un jeu de dupe en disant vous
déposez des milliers d'amendements nous
n'y avons pas au bout de l'examen du
texte mais eux ne voulait pas y aller la
preuve c'est que à la fin il y a eu 49,3
et parce qu'il y avait pas cette
majorité certaine à l'Assemblée
nationale donc cette obstruction
arrangeait évidemment l'exécutif avec
une opposition qui est avec une position
qui était intelligente elle aurait dû
justement faire en sorte on aille au
débat et piéger le gouvernement
là-dessus avec des arguments justement
et c'est parce que on a une opposition
qui n'a pas d'arguments et qui ne fait
que ça fait des bains on a vu les
communistes et les socialistes et les
collégistes vouloir aller jusqu'à
l'article 7 et la France insoumise qui
elle a refusé d'aller jusqu'à
l'articulation le problème il est là
aussi et du coup qui peut sortir gagnant
jeudi il y aura une discussion en séance
c'est celui qui ne dit rien c'est-à-dire
le rassemblement national si on en croit
les études d'opinion bon ça tout ça
reste à prouver quand même mais je pense
que personne
si on est dans l'absolu personne ne
s'organise de cette de cette histoire
donc je dis majorité ou la nuque que des
perdants le texte va passer et puis on
va passer à autre chose habilité de
toute façon l'article 40 sera excité par
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
parce que vous avez l'été qui arrive à
mon avis et ça c'était important
l'hypothèse qui tient la corde c'est que
il y ait une séance de 9h à midi que les
oppositions notamment la nuque violence
pour dénoncer les conditions d'examen du
texte qu'effectivement il y aura pas de
réintroduction de l'article 1 et que du
coup le texte vidait de sa substance
n'ira pas au bout
et on suivra ça ce sera évidemment la
semaine prochaine vous parliez du
rassemblement national le rassemblement
national qui a été pointé du doigt hier
pour ces liens avec la Russie dans un
rapport parlementaire sur les ingérences
étrangères d'une commission que le parti
avait lui-même demandé rapport qualité
lycée de malhonnête et politisée par
Marine Le Pen résumé des faits avec
Laura sauvage
bon le bas de combat ou rassemblement
national la commission d'enquête de
l'Assemblée nationale sur les ingérences
étrangères en France a rendu son rapport
hier il dénonce les liens entre le parti
de Marine Le Pen et la Russie de
Vladimir Poutine le rapport cite
l'ancienne ministre chargé des affaires
européennes Nathalie Loiseau auditionné
par la commission d'enquête le 6 avril
le circuit privilégié par Moscou pour
diffuser son influence en France et
comme ailleurs en Europe l’extrême
droite ce lien s'explique notamment par
une forte convergence de vue avec le
pouvoir russe sur un certain nombre de
valeurs politiques et de questions
géopolitiques ironie du sort la
commission d'enquête a été créée à
l'initiative du RN l'objectif était de
mettre en pièce les accusations
d'inféodation de Marine Le Pen à
Vladimir Poutine dont Emmanuel Macron
avait utilisé lors de l'entre-deux tours
de la campagne présidentielle mais après
six mois d'audition le rapport de la
Commission désigne le parti de Marine Le
Pen comme une courroie de transmission
efficace du Kremlin en France et
peut-être pas moins de 10 pages auprès
russe du RN sans toutefois apporter la
preuve d'un échange de services entre le
parti d'extrême droite et le régime de
Vladimir Poutine la réalité de ce
rapport c'est que rien en fait c'est à
dire que les gens qui nous ont accusés
n'ont aucun début de commencement
d'éléments factuels au total 30 députés
de tout bord politique ont siéger dans
cette commission d'enquête pas encore
publiée le rapport vire déjà à la
bataille rangée entre le RN et la
majorité présidentielle
il se rapporte qui est donc très dur
avec le rassemblement national un
courroie de transmission de la Russie
alors que c'est le rassemblement
national lui-même qui avait demandé
cette commission d'enquête sur les
ingérences étrangères pour couper court
justement aux arguments de ceux qui
disaient que il avait un lien avec la
Russie c'est quoi c'est le rassemblement
national prêt à son propre piège oui on
parlait de jeu tout à l'heure si on en
est pas loin là non plus
écoutez j'en sais rien moi ce que j'ai
pas lu le rapport pour dire la vérité je
ne connais pas
donc ce que je peux dire c'est que ce
que j'en entends et ce que disent les
uns et les autres c'est que j'ai pas
l'impression qu'il y ait le début du
commencement de preuve manifeste moi ce
qui m'intéresse je vais vous dire c'est
pas tellement de savoir si Madame Le Pen
relais les idées de Madame de Monsieur
Poutine je crois pas que ça soit
tellement le cas ce qui m'intéresse
c'est de savoir si elle est financée
et à quelle hauteur par des fonds qui
viennent éventuellement de la Russie
c'est ça qui m'intéresse le reste c'est
du bavardage
les accusations comporte contre Madame
Le Pen on peut les porter contre
monsieur Zemmour on peut les porter
contre Monsieur Mélenchon mais on a
voilà c'est c'est c'est quoi c'est des
commentaires c'est ça relève du
commentaire alors ce qui est assez la
procédure c'est pourquoi madame Le Pen a
réclamé cette commission cette
commission qui est présidée par un
membre du rassemblement national mais
dans leur rapporteur et quelqu'un de la
majorité qui ne veut qu'une chose c'est
faire du mal au rassemblement national
et encore j'en suis pas certain parce
qu'ils ont intérêt à ce que ce match
continue donc c'est c'est c'est assez
particulier
je suis pas certain non plus que les
conclusions telles qu'elles existent
aujourd'hui et si ça va pas plus loin et
bien tout ça ne fasse pas chic
finalement parce qu'on apprendra rien de
neuf donc ça ça peut pas nuire au
rassemblement national Arnaud c'est pas
quand même une erreur politique d'avoir
demandé cette commission d'enquête moi
je crois que ça aura très peu d'effet et
très peu d'impact dans l'opinion
publique bon il faut voir ce qu'il y a
dans le bon rapport on le verra la
semaine prochaine puisqu'il sera entendu
public la semaine prochaine mais je
rejoins ce que dit frère c'est que
finalement sur la question de la Russie
des liens avec la Russie le
rassemblement national n'est pas le seul
véritablement aujourd'hui la seule
formation politique qui puisse être mis
encore sur des liens avec la Russie ou
en tout cas sur des positions qui
seraient des positions bienveillantes
vis-à-vis de la Russie c'est assez
économiquement partagé sur le spectre
politique à gauche et à droite donc
c'est pour ça que ça aura un effet qui
sera qui sera à mon sens assez moindre
quant aux agences étrangères dans la vie
politique française si on commence à
faire le compte des ingérences
étrangères dans la vie politique
française je pense que beaucoup de
formations politiques et beaucoup de
responsables politiques peuvent être
parfois considérés comme étant eux-mêmes
je veux dire soumis à des formes
d'ingérence donc d'où qu'elle puisse
venir non je crois pas je crois pas que
ça pose véritablement un problème ce
qu'il faut quand même noter c'est que le
rapport sur le fond n'a pas été voté par
la plupart des parlementaires
d'ailleurs je note que la France
insoumise s'est abstenu ce qui est très
intéressant je note que beaucoup de LR
se sont également absolu et je note que
Monsieur Ramos du MoDem a considéré que
dans le rapport il n'y avait pas
d'éléments matériels qui lui permettait
de pouvoir émettre un ventre non ce qui
a derrière cela aussi c'est que c'est
une parlementaire qui est une
parlementaire de la majorité dans une
séquence politique très particulière sur
le positionnement de la majorité
vis-à-vis du rassemblement national et
ça fait suite aussi aux divergences
d'appréciations sur la nature du
rassemblement national entre la première
ministre et ils sont et le président de
la République donc il y a peut-être
aussi la volonté
on peut l'interpréter comme ça soyons
pas trop mauvaise n'ayons pas trop de
mauvais esprits mais on peut aussi
l'interpréter d'une certaine manière de
travailler un peu à la rhodiabolisation
du rassemblement national dans une
séquence où on considère que parfois
madame majorité ou en tout cas sont le
président de la République et peut-être
trop indulgent vis-à-vis du
rassemblement national
oui peut-être bon peut-être mais moi je
pense que tout ça ça va faire chier si
vous voulez il n'y a pas de il y a
effectivement regardez l'attitude des
uns et des autres comparés qui ont pas
voulu voter donc
sincèrement de la France ins juste pour
vous
peut-être faut pas sûr interpréter non
plus mais vous savez c'est vrai que les
ingérences il y a pas que si on fait le
calcul des sympathies plutôt que des
ingérences des uns et des autres on a
une émission dans suffit de suffira pas
les sympathies vis-à-vis de certains
régimes du Moyen-Orient de certains
régimes africains de
la chaîne on peut on peut fantasmer dans
tous les sens et depuis très longtemps
moi ce qui m'interroge c'est
l'utilisation de rapport parlementaire
pour effectivement mener cette bataille
politique de la part de la majorité ce
que nous au Sénat on a plutôt
l'expérience de rapport parlementaire
qui sont trans partisans avec un
président souvent de droite ou de gauche
et un rapporteur qui est du camp
l'inverse et à la fin une commission
d'enquête qui essaye de se mettre
d'accord sur les conclusions on avait vu
avec l'affaire Benalla rappelez-vous
c'était Philippe Bas pour aller aller à
Jean-Pierre sur les pour les socialistes
on avait vu la femme McKinsey avec une
rapporteur qui était qui était
communiste il y en assi un président à
nos bases d'enquêter LR et à la fin ça
rendait les rapports beaucoup plus
puissants alors qu'il lorsqu'il était
rendu public parce que il y avait pas la
question d'une guéguerre politique sur
les conclusions du rapport et à
l'Assemblée nationale on voit que c'est
pas du tout la démarche qui a été
choisie et donc pas du tout je pense ça
affaiblit le le rapport à la fin
non c'est sûr que ça je pense que c'est
c'est pas un rapport qui va rester et
qui va nous donner la vérité du
rassemblement national ce qui est
intéressant c'est vrai mais personne ne
l'a vraiment souligné c'est que ça
intervient dans un différent entre le
Premier ministre la première ministre
que le Président de la République et
c'est assez cocasse à relever
tout a été dit je crois que tout a été
dit allez on passe
à la du vendredi on va prendre un peu
l'air on est en plein Roland Garros vous
le savez même s'il y a plus de français
on va rencontrer Pauline Déroulède
Jean-Pierre championne de tennis
fauteuil numéro 1 française elle a été
renversée par un chauffard en 2018
amputé de la jambe gauche et depuis elle
mène un double combat remporté les Jeux
paralympiques de Paris 2024 et mettre
fin au permis de conduire à vie Flora
sauvage est allé la rencontrer dans les
Yvelines où elle se prépare pour Roland
Garros sans rien
en 2018 j'ai été victime d'un accident
de la route malheureusement j'ai été
fauché sur un trottoir parisien dans
lequel j'ai perdu ma jambe gauche il
s'agissait d'un monsieur très âgé qui
n'avait plus de réflexe qui a appuyé sur
l'accélérateur au lieu du frein et c'est
vrai que ce jour-là ma vie bascule j'ai
un endroit moins j'ai évidemment été
hospitalisé de longs mois j'ai pu
remarcher au bout de quatre mois grâce à
une prothèse et à ce moment là j'ai pu
vraiment reprendre possession de mon
corps en rééducation de réapprendre à
marcher avant son accident Pauline
Déroulède faisait du tennis en loisir
désormais classé numéro une en France de
tennis fauteuil féminin 16ème au niveau
mondial elle vise les Jeux paralympiques
Paris 2024 c'est l'objectif de d'une vie
c'est l'objectif qui m'a permis de
d'arriver où je suis aujourd'hui qui m'a
cette nouvelle vie qui m'a fait rebondir
après cet accident dans lequel j'ai
perdu ma jambe je n'ai pas envie de me
contenter de participer à cet événement
j'ai envie de de gagner je vise un po
tout petit peu plus long tout petit peu
comme ça
accident c'est vrai que j'avais
énormément de colère entre ce monsieur
qui n'aurait pas dû prendre le volant ce
jour-là et très rapidement j'ai
manifesté
l'envie la juge d'instruction de
rencontrer ce monsieur c'était un moment
très fort avec monsieur qui aurait pu
être mon grand-père il y a eu des mots
très forts de sa part comme quoi s'il y
avait une loi pour l'empêcher de
conduire il leur a respecté depuis son
accident Pauline Déroulède milite pour
la fin du permis de conduire ravi pour
que au cours d'une vie tous les
conducteurs puissent repasser devant le
médecin pour tester leur aptitude à la
conduite avec une fréquence plus
régulière à partir d'un certain âge mais
le combat de Pauline Déroulède ne
s'arrête pas là la championne de France
a dû se familiariser avec le fauteuil
roulant au tennis quand on joue debout
et quand on lit la trajectoire de la
balle c'est les connexions en euros qui
se font c'est les jambes qui déclenchent
le mouvement et là c'est totalement
averser une fauteuil c'est le haut du
corps donc il faut arriver à
déconstruire toute cette fonctionnement
voilà qui est assez inné moi ça a été
beaucoup de frustration au début quand
j'ai démarré il a fallu ce familiariser
avec ce fauteuil d'abord rouler sans
raquettes comprendre comment réagissait
le fauteuil moi c'était tout nouveau
j'étais jamais monté dans un fauteuil de
ma vie donc au début c'était c'était dur
parce que je voyais passer les balles à
droite à gauche que j'avais debout mais
que là il fallait accepter de pas avoir
de plus avoir dans un premier temps
parce qu'il fallait d'abord maîtriser ce
fauteuil donc il a fallu s'armer de
patience de beaucoup de détermination
donc voilà j'ai essayé d'aller le plus
vite possible pour rattraper mon retard
et aujourd'hui c'est plutôt satisfaite
parce que parce que je roule pas trop
mal
en attendant les JO Pauline Déroulède va
multiplier les tournois prochaine étape
Roland Garros pour la compétition de
tennis fauteuil
voilà on souhaite bonne chance
évidemment Pauline et roulettes pour
Roland Garros c'est la semaine prochaine
notre partage du vendredi on part à la
découverte des bateaux de l'Armada de
Rouen vous verrez ça quand on regarde ce
qu'elle a une de la presse régionale
c'est parti
[Musique]
et quand on commence par une forte
émotion c'était hier les obsèques de
l'infirmière poignardée à Reims tout à
fait la presse raconte cet adieux à
Karen poignardé à mort le 22 mai dernier
au CHU de Reims une cérémonie
particulièrement émouvante peut-on lire
dans la presse régionale sa famille et
Ségolène ses collègues ont dit à Dieu
alors rayon de soleil écrit même
l'Ardennais dans les pages intérieures
du journal on lit le récit de cette
cérémonie et les maux de la merde à
l'infirmière qui a raconté le parcours
de sa fille qui a travaillé dans
l'humanitaire par exemple au Burkina
Faso la maman a qui termine avec ses
mots Karen tu es parti trop tôt tu as
disparition nous met en colère et soude
encore plus notre petit clan familial
autre drame terrible c'est le suicide de
l'Insee collégienne de 13 ans et c'est
la Une de La Voix du Nord si on avait
été aidé ma fille serait encore parmi
nous sa famille a dénoncé l'inaction
face au harcèlement connu que subissait
la jeune fille explique le Journal de
l'île quatre plaintes ont été déposés on
retient les larmes de sa qu'on voit la
Une du journal et en conférence de
presse elle me manque à telle lâché dans
un sanglot
dans la presse régionale et la visite
sous
-claure c'est ce que raconte le cours de
l'Ouest tout à fait regardez protégé par
un service d'ordre conséquent Elisabeth
borne a fui tout contact avec la foule
comme avec la presse hier c'est ce qui
écrit le journal au moment de lancer
pourtant le service public de la petite
enfance c'est ce que raconte donc le
journal d'Angers elle n'aura pas entendu
donc les casseroles de ses opposants à
compte encore le titre ils étaient
pourtant près de 200 réunis place du
chapeau de gendarme à Angers avant une
déambulation vite stoppée dit le journal
allez contente quand même par votre
touche du vendredi le Conseil sorti du
week-end c'est dans Presse Océan
face à cette actualité très lourde mais
voilà une flottie de 200 embarcations
qui doit parader sur le fleuve demain on
le voit le journal et donc il y a aussi
ce bateau véthique et le joyau du
patrimoine fluvial nantais si vous êtes
dans la région l'occasion de prendre un
grand bol d'air merci Quentin la Une du
Figaro Yves dette est déficit la France
sous haute surveillance
vieux sujet puisque la France je vous le
rappelle n'a pas voté un seul budget à
l'équilibre depuis 1974 alors pourquoi
on évoque ce sujet ce soir ce matin
parce que ce soir on attend une décision
d'un
agence de natation qui s'appelle
standard en cours et on a déjà été
dégradé avec l'agence Fitch il y a
quelques semaines et là on s'attend
peut-être c'est pas évident peut-être
qu'il se passera rien à ce qu'on soit
encore dégradé par cette agence qui pèse
l'ours et une des agences de plus
respectées donc on a l'impression de
revenir aussi 10 10 12 ans en arrière
quand tout le monde était vraiment
impatient de savoir ce qui va se passer
le pouvoir des agences a un peu diminué
quand même aussi mais enfin la France
dépense toujours autant d'argent public
et ce matin dans Le Figaro la une de la
revue politique et parlementaire
s'excore et politique des lésions
tumultueuse Arnaud une nouvelle formule
pour un nouveau départ son temps après
parlementaire merci beaucoup à lundi
merci beaucoup Arnaud Arnaud pour
vendredi comme Quentin
si vous voulez voir revoir cette
émission c'est sur notre nouvelle
plateforme public sénat.fr on se
retrouve lundi on vous souhaite un
excellent weekend
[Musique]